I want to thank you all in advance for
trusting me with the souls of your
departed loved ones um so I am actually
going to start with the mom that is
departed and she started to labor my
breathing um so is your mom departed yes
your mom is so excited and she's like oh
my God oh my God this is my baby girl
you don't understand I don't want my
daughter to feel that I am missing out
on any of her Milestones so did you get
married after your mom are you getting
married yeah I got married after she
passed away validating for you that your
mom attended your wedding in spirit she
also shows me this single seat with the
red rose and the picture that is just my
symbol for that you did something in
memory of her yes okay there are four
young Souls that just stepped forward
that he's that telling me that they died
suddenly and tragically because I can
taste the blood I I lost I lost a friend
but why did you just get like a chill or
Goose my whole body is know that that
was the soul moving through you to
validate the presence now is this like a
brother to you or were they you just
very close cuz I felt this Bond do you
you understand that it was like this
brother and how do you connect with the
tree um was there something with the
tree was there a tree planted in memory
of him there was oh my God okay and I
don't know does he have a sister he does
he says please he just took red roses
and handed them to the sister and said
please send my love to my sister oh my
God he but I feel like he will take any
opportunity to throw you under the bus
no it's so fun he's like let me tell you
a few things about him
he looks like he's so nice and innocent
let me tell you the things he used to do
is yeah yeah we just had a lot of fun
together he says but I want to thank you
for remembering that not losing sight
yeah or like allowing the way that I
died to Define who I was do you
understand that course never yeah how do
you connect with the dad that has
departed my dad did you not get the
opportunity to say goodbye to your dad I
did not no cuz he showed me the holding
of the hands and the whispering of the
ear which means that nothing was left
unsaid so know that everything and
anything that you said to your your dad
and then your dad looked at me goes can
you believe I died I go no I can't but
would that sound like your dad or his
Personality yeah do you understand that
and yes he was I was seven and he he
declined very rapidly so it was hard for
me to grasp at the time your dad said to
me that you still have that picture of
you and him cuz he shows me this it's
just my symbol it's he's I I think he's
wearing a white T-shirt or like a
t-shirt and um and then he goes I don't
know why you didn't tell it first that
how handsome I was in the picture he
goes all right but anyway let me move on
like so your dad must have had like a a
a sense of humor or very funny he says
please let my daughter know that this is
my favorite picture as well cuz I feel
like you were really little like I don't
know if you were like three or four but
your dad was holding you and he's in
this t-shirt and he has this cool hair
and he's just so handsome yeah we were
in Cape Cod and he was holding me and we
were by like this this Lobster um thing
yeah yeah that's wild so valadan that
when you look at this picture or
something that maybe you treasure know
that your dad's soul is with you at
these exact moments